when I talk about Community Health one
of the aspects of that that we do think
about a lot that I think about a lot is
not about politics it's just like how
are we treating newcomers to the
community and so I can tell you what our
ideals are what our philosophy is
um but do we live up to that so you know
the ideal is you come to Wikipedia you
know we have uh rules like one of our
fundamental rules is ignore all rules
which is partly written that way because
it piques people's attention like what
what the hell kind of rule is that you
know but basically says look don't get
nervous and depressed about a bunch of
you know what's the formatting of your
footnote right so you shouldn't come to
Wikipedia add a link and then get banned
or yelled at because it's not the right
format
uh instead somebody should go oh hey
yeah thanks for for helping but you know
here's the link to how to format uh you
know if you want to keep going you might
want to learn how to format a footnote
um and and to be friendly and to be open
and to say oh right oh you're new and
you clearly don't know everything about
Wikipedia and you know sometimes in any
community that can be quite hard so
people come in and they've got a great
big idea and they're going to propose
this to the Wikipedia community and they
have no idea
that's basically a perennial discussion
we've had seven thousand times before
and so then ideally you would say to the
person oh yeah great thanks like a lot
of people have and here's where we got
to and here's the nuanced conversation
we've had about that in the past that I
think you'll find interesting and
sometimes people are just like oh God
another one you know who's come in with
this idea which doesn't work and they
don't understand why I can lose patience
but they shouldn't and that's kind of
human you know but I think it just does
require really thinking you know uh in a
in a
self-aware manner of like oh I was once
a newbie actually we do have we have a
great I just did an interview with the
uh
uh Emily Temple Woods who she was
Wikipedia of the year she's just like a
great well-known wikipedian and I
interviewed her for my book and she told
me something I never knew apparently
it's not secret like she didn't reveal
it to me but is that when she started
Wikipedia she was a vandal she came in
and vandalized Wikipedia and then
basically what happened was she'd done
some sort of uh vandalized a couple of
Articles and then somebody popped up on
her talk page and said hey like why are
you doing this like we're trying to make
an encyclopedia here and this wasn't
very kind yeah and she felt so bad
she's like oh right I didn't really
think of it that way she just was coming
in as she was like 13 years old
combative and you know like having fun
and trolling a bit and then she's like
oh actually oh I see your point and
became a great wikipedian so that's the
ideal really is that you don't just go
throw a block [__] off yeah you go hey
you know like what what goes you know
which is I think uh the way
we tend to treat things in real life you
know if you've got somebody who's doing
something obnoxious in your friend group
you'd probably go hey like really
I I don't know if you've noticed but I
think this person is actually quite hurt
that you keep making that joke about
them and then they usually go oh you
know what I didn't I thought that was
okay I didn't and then they stop or they
keep it up and then everybody goes well
you're the [__]
well yeah I mean that's just an example
that gives me Faith in humanity that uh
that we're all capable and
um wanting to be kind to each other and
in general this the fact that there's a
small group of volunteers
they're able to contribute so much to
the organization The Collection uh the
uh the discussion of all of human
knowledge is so it makes me so grateful
to be a part of this whole human project
I that's one of the reasons I love
Wikipedia it gives me Faith in humanity
no I I once was
um
at uh wikimaney is our annual conference
and people come from all around the
world like really active volunteers
I was at the dinner we were in Egypt at
wikimanian Alexandria at the sort of
closing dinner or whatever and a friend
of mine came and sat at the table and
she's sort of been in the movement more
broadly Creative Commons she's not
really Wikipedia she'd come to the
conference because she's into Creative
Commons and all that
so we have dinner and it just turned out
I sat down at the table with most of the
members of the English language
arbitration committee and they're a
bunch of very sweet
geeky wikipedians and as we left the
table I said to her it's really like I
still find this kind of sense of
Amazement like we just had dinner with
some of the most powerful people in
English language media because they're
the people who are like the final court
of appeal in English Wikipedia and thank
goodness they're not medium Moguls right
they're just a bunch of Geeks Who are
just like well liked in the community
because they're kind and they're
thoughtful and they really you know sort
of think about things I was like this is
great love YouTube video it's like to
the degree that Geeks
run the best aspect of human
civilization brings me joy in all
aspects and this is true in programming
like Linux yeah uh like programmers in
all like people that kind of specialize
in a thing
and they don't really get caught up in
into the mess of the bickering of of uh
Society they just kind of do their thing
yeah and they value the craftsmanship of
it yeah the competence of it if you if
you've never heard of this or looked
into it you'll enjoy it I read something
recently that I didn't even know about
but like
the the the fundamental like time zones
and and they change from time to time
you know sometimes a country will pass
daylight savings or move it by a week
whatever there's a file
uh that's done all you know sort of Unix
based computers and basically all
computers end up using this file it's
the official time zone file but why is
it official it's just this one guy yeah
it's like this guy and a group a
community around him and basically
something something weird happened
and it broke something because he was on
vacation and I'm just like isn't that
wild right that you would think I mean
first of all most people never even
think about like how do computers know
about time zones
um well they know because they just use
this file which tells all the time zones
and and which dates they change and all
of that but there's this one guy and he
doesn't get paid for it it's just he's
like you know with all the billions of
people on the planet he sort of put his
hand up and goes yo I'll take care of
the time zones and there's a lot a lot a
lot of programmers listening to this
right now with PTSD about time zones and
then there uh I mean there's on top of
this one guy there's other libraries the
different programming languages that
help manage the time zones for you but
still there's just within those there's
it's amazing just the packages the
libraries how few people build oh yeah
out of their own love
for building for creating for community
and all of that yeah it's uh I honestly
don't want to interfere with the natural
habitat of the geek like when you spot
them in the wall you just want to be
like yeah well careful yeah that thing
no I treasured I met a guy many years
ago
um lovely really sweet guy and he's
running a bot on English Wikipedia
that I thought wow that's actually super
clever what he had done is
his bot was like spell checking but
rather than simple spell checking what
he had done is create a database of
words that are commonly mistaken for
other words they're spelled wrong so I
can't even give an example
and so the word is people often spell it
wrong but no spell checker catches it
because it is another word
and so what he did is he wrote a bot
that looks for these words and then
checks the sentence around it for
certain keywords so in in some context
uh
this isn't correct but buoy and boy
people sometimes type Boi when they mean
b-o-u-y so if he sees the word boy be a
y in an article he would look in the
context and see is this a nautical
reference and if it was he didn't auto
correct he just would flag it up to
himself to go oh check this one out and
that's not a great example but he had
thousands of examples and I was like
that's amazing like I would have never
thought to do that and I'm glad that
somebody did and that's also part of the
openness of the system and also I think
being a charity being you know this idea
of like actually this is a gift to the
world uh that makes someone go oh oh
well I'll put my hand up like I see a
little piece of things that I can make
better because I'm a good programmer and
I can write this script to do this thing
and I'll find it fun
amazing